For all that I have done,...
...I am so sorry.
I have a lot to atone for...
...but there is one issue I really want to discuss.
Some people have speculated that Elin somehow hurt...
...or attacked me on Thanksgiving night.
It angers me that people would fabricate a story like that.
Elin never hit me that night or any other night.
There has never been an episode of domestic violence in our marriage, ever.
Elin has shown enormous grace and poise throughout this ordeal.
Elin deserves praise, not blame.
The issue involved here was my repeated irresponsible behavior.
I was unfaithful.
I had affairs.
I cheated.
What I did is not acceptable...
...and I am the only person to blame.
I stopped living by the core values that I was taught to believe in.
I knew my actions were wrong...
...but I convinced myself that normal rules didn't apply.
I never thought about who I was hurting.
Instead, I thought only about myself.
I ran straight through the boundaries that a married couple should live by.
I thought I could get away with whatever I wanted to.
I felt that I had worked hard my entire life...
...and deserved to enjoy all the temptations around me.
I felt I was entitled.
Thanks to money and fame,...
...I didn't have to go far to find them.